In the previous video on Nefron we talked about the
The different parts of the nephron and how (as I think) the molecules
Re-absorbed in the body and different parts
In (as you remember) the nearby winding pipes
We also talked about glucose, amino acids and sodium
Re-absorbed
We talked about the rising part of Henle
We talked about salts such as sodium, potassium, chloride and chlorine
Which are re-absorbed
In the far-flung tubes
Including calcium and other molecules
But at least in my mind when I first studied it, I wondered
How does that happen?
How we actively pump those particles out, especially
Against their concentration?
What I want to do in this video is to dig deeper
In what exactly happens on the boundaries
Those tubes allow those ions to
It is selectively moved outside the cavity or inside
Those pipes or
Recycled from leachate
This technique (logically) is similar in
The different parts of the Nefron but to take a look
On each part separately because each part absorbs
Different types of molecules
I will not classify all the molecules but only
I will give you a brief about it
Let's start with the nearby anibles here
Let us, for example, enlarge that part
So let me draw the inner part of the nephron
The inner part of the nephron can
That sounds like this
If this part is internal
This is the liquid leachate here specifically
In fact, let me paint it
A little different from that
If the inner part, I will draw it so because
The nearby anipoles have those small adhesive parts
Sometimes it is called brush border
If here is the inner part this is the cavity
Here is where the liquid is leachate
The glomerular leachate comes in this direction
So, you can imagine the inner part of the Nephron
And then the wall of the built-in anode
Pack of cells
So there can be a cell here and this is another cell here
That is another cell
To illustrate, this is a cross-section
It will actually be cylindrical
It will look like this somehow
This is only to illustrate the idea
Here is another cell
The base part may be precisely here
When we say basal we can imagine it
Represents the cell rule
Those are good words to know words
If the cellular part is facing the cavity or
Facing the inner part of the nape is called b
The holy side
Thus this segment usually refers to the lateral basal segment
Or this membrane that I referred to as a membrane
The basal membrane will be lateral
This is true regardless of which part of the nephrons we are
Either in the nearby anibilis or in the Henle class
Or even in remote anibodies
What we have here, and the other aspects of these cells
Here we have bristles surrounding the tubes
This is also a distinctive word
If the capillaries around the tubules look something like this
In fact cells are also
Instead of drawing the cells I will draw them only
And as a kind of pipe I will paint it like this
They are full of pores
There is blood flowing from here
There is blood here
this too
I will not explain too much detail to cells
Capillaries
I really want to explain how molecules move
Outside the cavity and how it is reclaimed
Selectively
So here we find the capillaries around Annibiba
Again the word is distinct but peri means
About like a perimeter
If the pipes are surrounded
These filaments surround the tubes
If we focus on this picture we will find
The capillaries surround all the tubes
So when the material is excreted or re-absorbed outside
Nephrons, they flow with blood inside those capillaries
If this membrane is encapsulated tubules
Which is close here
Let's example see what happens to glucose
What really happens here is because of the sodium and potassium pumps
On the lateral basal portion of those cells
This sodium and potassium pump
I will draw one here specifically
You can watch your private video
With sodium and potassium pumps
I have a complete video to explain how it works
But the idea here is that sodium can be painted here
As positive particles that will join the inner part
Here specifically, the ATP molecules will come
When ATP molecules enter the right part of the protein
The shape and shape of the protein will change
The protein will close this side here and open that side
In this form and form can not manage sodium
Of a longer period of protein-related bonding and separation
Outside or passing through the lateral basal membrane
And finally goes to the blood
And then on the other side a sodium and potassium pump
When they are somewhat open I will draw them here
I also have a full video on this point
Where potassium tends to bind
So potassium tends to bind to it
Linked to it in this area, for example
This is just a simple and general explanation
What happens makes the protein change its formation
ATP consumption is not required at this point, and then returns
For this formation, and therefore will not be able to potassium
Of protein-related resistance is released due to
Change the shape of the protein
If the general idea here: sodium is related
The ATP molecules are linked
The phosphate group is separated
This causes the protein to change
Now sodium needs to be released and potassium is to be released
To link
When the potassium is linked we return to the original state
The final result is that our sodium has been
We pump it out of the cell and we also have potassium
Pump it into the cell and this is called active transport
Why Transport (active)?
Because ATP has been consumed to transport sodium opposite
Concentrate to keep sodium out of the cell
And then the potassium moves to enter the cell you can almost
imagine that
No ATP consumption is required
This is why the pump is usually called the sodium and potassium pump ATPase
The enzyme ATPase is a protein or enzyme responsible
About ATP cracking
ATP breaks and uses the resulting energy to change
The pump is pumped into the sodium and the potassium inside
Well, for all, it's all a review of what we learned
In previous videos, but how can this help us? for example
To remove the glucose from the cavity
Well, what we have here is a bunch of other proteins
We will take only the example of glucose
Let's say we have a protein here
There is a general term for that protein
A co transporter or a symporter
This means that the protein transmits two types of molecules
same direction
co transporter means that one of the particles tends to move
Because of gradient difference in focus while segment
The other somewhat moves in its
So you can imagine, that the sodium was pumped out
So here we pump sodium out on the part
Basal lateralization, a decrease in concentration will occur
Sodium is here
The greater the pumping out, the lower the concentration
Finally, sodium concentration will decrease
For its concentration in the cavity
If the gradient in the concentration of sodium in the absence
Membrane here, sodium will need to pass through it
To compensate for the lack of sodium concentration here
The sodium will pass through it if there is no barrier
These cells exploit the need for sodium
To move in the direction of gradient in its concentration
(Which resulted from the active transport here) but is exploited
The energy resulting from the transition of sodium to the direction of low concentration
To move some particles
Glucose in this case, for example
So if you imagine that you can imagine a protein
On the membrane here
They may bleed so
This helps you to imagine
You may have more sodium on this side than there is
On that side, so sodium tends to link here
Glucose may be linked here
This is just a simplification, but when linked
This protein changes its shape to be more like
So when they are connected, now sodium becomes
Here and glucose becomes here
Now we are inside the cell, and
In this morphology, do not tend to link strongly
Amino acids or anything else in the protein and then
They are free
When released, the protein will change
It will revert to what it was here and we can repeat this cycle
Again and so on
But all this is conditioned by the principle of higher concentration
Sodium is here to be pumped to this point until it is allowed to
Interaction occurs
So sodium moves in the direction of gradient concentration
It takes glucose in its
Of course, glucose concentration will increase
Here, and then can glucose
The passage through the follicles will finally move the glucose
(If it rises sufficiently) will move in a direction
Graduation in the concentration in the direction of blood
The same process completely occurs or maybe not quite
With glucose but through all nephrons
If we go to the Henle class to the rising part specifically
Here, where we try to get the salts out of
Picture, we will find the same idea
Let's assume that the cavity is located here
This is a cell which is a cavity construction unit
We are now inside the Henle class and you have
Sodium and Potassium Pump Here
You have sodium that is pumped out
Potassium was pumped into the inside but in fact
Potassium channels are few, so sometimes potassium can be low
To return in the other direction
So what happens to
Potassium is not important
But since sodium concentration is less here
So we have here sympators as we had in case
Glucose, but in this case sodium needs to enter
It was also in the case of glucose but here we try
Transfer of chlorine and potassium ions
So here's what will happen
Where sodium will be used
In the direction of its concentration
It will become our potassium and we will become
Chlorine ions
So the symporter here is called
sodium-potassium-chlorine co transporter
This is the second diversity found in
The ascending part of Henle
So the US will end up with lots of chlorine ions
Here, in fact (potassium enters from both directions) but
As long as this is porous for chlorine, then this
The concentration has risen sufficiently to turn the chlorine
To exit and help to form the area of ​​the spinal cord
The higher the sodium salts
The same thing in the far-flung tubules
Where calcium is found
It's a bit different
So if we were in the far-flung annealed tubes, that kind
Of the villi, those adhesives are only found in
Close bends
But there, as you know that idea where we were
We use the gradient in concentration (resulting from
Some types of active transport) in the transfer of other materials
This is called secondary active transport
It's good to know
Let's end up in the far-flung tubes
If this is the cavity
Suppose that the cavity here is specifically so we have
Cells on both sides
I think you understand the general idea
This remote part is a bit different so let's say
This is a cell, let's assume that this is a bloody ritual surrounding
By the tube here
This is blood
What we have here is again
Sodium has been pumped out
Sodium and potassium pump
I have a whole video talking about it and if potassium is pumped inside
So you end up with a lot of sodium here
Membrane membrane facing cavity
Porous for calcium
Whatever the concentration of calcium here
Will be here
So you may have calcium
These calcium ions are scattered in the ocean
Here specifically, there is Antiporter
If sodium concentration in the blood will become
Higher due to continued pumping out
The sodium will therefore move towards its concentration
He goes back inside
Here you may have some sodium moving towards its low concentration
So he will come back inside again and so
You can most likely imagine it as a genre
From the rotary doors, the calcium is pushed out
You can visualize how your protein can be
To do so
I can imagine it as a rotten kebab
Sodium makes the door spin
And calcium p the other part of the door
To drive him out
If this is called an antiporter it is transmitted
In different directions but again he moved active
Secondary, because the only way this interaction occurs
Conditioned by the presence of an active transport that consumes ATP resulting from the release of sodium
Outside the lateral basal membrane in each of these cases
Whatever, I hope it is useful
It contains a lot of unusual detail
Nephrons normally pump material out of the cavity
In the direction of the capillaries around the tubes but for me, so make
Things are more specific
He really helped me to understand
What are the Nephrons in particular